less than 30 seconds one minute time
control a war zone rated 112 players
have entered so far check that 114
average rating 1806 time handicap time
will be adjusted according to rating
anybody could enter no experience level
required and here we go
alright he doubled the points double the
points and I was wondering where that
little timer was there it is
let's go bishop quick kill scholars mate
no I'm gonna try this this is a really
bad idea but I'm gonna do it I should
have played c3 actually is this working
I got a piece oh oh let's stop that
Knight from getting excited about the d4
square let's go let's go give a check
right here's good enough I should take
an f7 maybe I'll take it next let's do
this what's the count
wow look at my time no time control f5
back up if the knight hits my bishop get
all my pieces out just take that guy in
a castle I want to get to f5 time
situation got a piece really quick right
there my rook is close to dead but I
could grab a six oh I gotta watch out
for some stuff here okay this is a
little scary actually why did I take
like that okay I thought there could be
a capture of my rook wow where did my
time go I don't any time don't tell me
I'm gonna lose this give me that rook go
after my night oh they're being sneaky
come on come on come on come on come on
come on yes two pawns passed like this
are very strong
okay I got this one two three one two
and then three coming up unavoidable
what how much time and I start off with
in that game why that go down to the
wire back to tournament two's bunch of
two's okay okay
okay double the points c5 land hang on
what's white gonna throw of me oh I
thought okay they're they're playing
here we go
Queen c7 they thought I was gonna play
Knight there does that really matter all
the anti fishing pole or is it I might
insist I might insist that my knight
gets there since they insist you're not
stopping me you can't stop the night oh
it's back on be very scared be very
scared be very scared light square
weaknesses oh oh
fishing pole and fishing pole land
where's the main where's the main okay I
could just calmly come back right it's
okay to do that I got this making one
threat I'm on the bishop I have have to
recovered oh there's a big trouble big
trouble very big trouble
Knight right here stop Knight their King
f2o
resignation time Clark ticker is it a
clock ticker my P clock ticker 20 19 18
and it happens all rightie they were
fear in the fishing pole they got hooked
they they they took a bite at the
Nightcrawler mmm
okay back to tournament six six six a
bunch of sixes five four threes all
right double the points
this guy has six points okay he's having
a good tournament so far - okay okay we
have this earlier oh this is a different
one okay I'm up I'm up upon Forex Forex
everywhere just look familiar it should
know castling I'm on the bishop checks
give a check pins everywhere kill the
night kill a rook they're gonna take
this part I want to get rid of the light
square bishop what's happening here oh
man
my rooks are in good shape here what's
the scoop okay we have um an ending here
and I just want to move quick here okay
so in this endgame what what's the scoop
here King position King physician get
your King in a good position he's in a
good position now let's go upon your
past do something good box-out the
knight trade I'm a baby step it baby
step it baby step well no no no no no
Mouse lives don't you dare get to safe
square bishop avoid any nonsense avoid
the nonsense
let's go pawn push don't move your king
don't move your king I wanted to click
me
let's go upon okay they resigned back to
tournament twelves twelves 11 and 10
here we go here we go oh somebody has 14
this guy has 14 oh the leader of the
pack can the leader of the pack fall for
the fishing pole ah be very scared
it's happening oh it's engaged there's
the hook
there's the bait okay
now found for it ah oh it's a little
scary to do that I'm in a pin Oh is
there trouble or what I think there's
trouble defend oh it's very scary over
here very very very scary no I can't
allow stuff to open up don't you dare no
I don't want to open up oh it's scary
night right here big trouble for me oh
very scary my king just wants to go
somewhere safe where's the safe square
is this safe
oh my Knights dead that's all right
hit the Queen give a check give a check
here come on Bishop do something good
okay oh I shouldn't have done that I
shouldn't have done that I'm in trouble
I want to cry
okay wait they didn't take that what's
the time situation right here everything
all right
I have this what do we have
I just want to trade just trade even if
it's wrong I want to trade Oh trade
please just trade come on they're gonna
give a check though Oh defend defend
defend look at my stupid rook what a
stupid piece really really stupid do I
have this whoo I think I might have it
that's a killing move no it's not I had
something better there what's the time
situation just take here please just
trade a little bit trade come on come on
come on come on Trix Trix Trix look
tricks just anything anything just I'm
gonna do it even if it's wrong
check check check check check time hers
time burners time burners time burners
where are you at time burners more time
burners more time burners that's it's
better than 2.10 and everybody loves a
time burner okay here we go
efore oh I have no idea what I'm saying
okay why am i gone with this really
Lopez in these one-minute games I'm
really looking for strategical play no
no get out of there oh okay
kill the night go after the light square
Bishop light square Bishop you need to
go no no no no no no gonna try to trap
them I try to trap them let's go kill
the bishop push up on get out of there
night oh the Knights just gonna go there
isn't he he is yeah he's definitely
going there isn't it he's definitely
going here or here I'm not gonna take
the bishop just yet
okay maybe queenside castle uh yeah I
better queenside castle it's scary over
here uh-oh I got a pun got a pun Oh pin
the night
things are good oh the Queen's cooked
cooked Queen resignation resignation
back to tournament 56-37 what 56 don't
you dare resigned to that top guy 20
minutes left a lot of time a lot of time
don't you dare count me out I'm gonna
get this alright let's go this guy's
making me wait look it he's telling me
right there you better wait there's the
clock if you wonder in 20 minutes and 10
seconds remaining okay time to do some
home cookin 54 Oh 54 54 8 games all we
drop back come on gimme it can't be with
the air and give me points don't start
this game
give me just a Nair and give me the
points let me play another person
because they're not firing this one up
there clearly just making me wait right
here I can't I'm afraid to turn away
because I don't have a pre move on can I
look at a different game there's another
game they might start it's not starting
give the air let's go home this is
brutal this is brutal can't get into
rhythm yes air give me the points how
many points did I get how many points
did I drop back now I got six points for
it okay I got six Kings gambit land
oh there could be problems no problems
14 black f7 pawn push in the center d4
coming up or is it pawn push pawn push
kill the bishop I really can't
Oh f7 f 7 f7 I'm gonna take here Knight
f6 may be needed
what's that cleanup - I'm going after f7
uh-oh
this could be a problem this could be a
big problem I'm on f7 pawn push also is
threatened uh-oh tempo queenside castle
I'm gonna keep my punt
oh wait what's going on I'm gonna do
this actually I'm threatening to win the
clean and I'm gonna take this pawn push
next no I can't do it if it's not there
you can't do east six if you don't have
a pawn on e5 can you okay where's my
knight think he's going oh man okay
let's get some trades in here kick this
night away a little bit what us okay
good
he wasn't doing anything over there
anyhow and I want to keep my Bishop
after all how much time get out of there
Knight I'm just gonna do that even if
he's trapped he's gonna be trapped with
that but that's alright I have a
connected past pawn I just want their
time to burn and I want to create a
weakness here and they're not
allow me that g5 you're gonna stop that
- no okay I get some play over here I'm
on the rook h6 is what I want f6 gonna
be played h6 okay looking for me the
bishops in a good spot Oh check and then
mate check check and then mean as
fumbling once again okay they're not
down on time seventy seven seventy 67
56:48 let's go this guy as negative he's
in the negative here okay can we get a
quick win somehow what's that clean up -
oh they resigned back to tournament oh
oh hey God 60 to 62 vs. 26 ok fantasy
this is a strong player ok let's go
let's roll ok get out of there night oh
oh light squares light squares light
squares light squares here it is f6 okay
Castle and then what get out of there
clean you have no business being in my
territory
get out Knight I don't want you to go
here that's that's gonna bother me
okay I'm gonna chase you away clamp down
light squares light squares light
squares right here okay right here's a
good idea and right okay I'll take that
let's go Knight my other night needs to
do something good he's doing nothing
good past pond the night is that he has
to go home he's gotta go home huh oh
that's a scary place that's a scary
place right there
this night needs to do something he's
stupid let's go Knight here next oh oh
oh
I was actually on that pun let's break
this open what's this Knight - and he's
stuck he's a stuck night he's stuck
uh-oh I could keep pushing passant
connected passed pawns coming up brutal
brutal pawns here uh-oh I could probably
still take that night I'm gonna take
like this
and then like this and then there's like
checks and stuff isn't there let's just
pile up on this f6 is falling down real
fast isn't it right here f6 is hit a ton
of times it can't be hit it anymore
oh man this is me right you got a block
where's the Queen gonna go one of those
two
that's me back determined 78 105 88-78
105 Knapp three okay okay
temple gainer or not okay no this one
first 14 minutes and change hang out
let's see where the night goes you might
have been sneaky okay let's go to Bishop
d6 d4 fishing fishing fishing going
fishing beware
oh they sniffed it out or did they I'm
still gonna go for it come on you could
do it oh man I guess here I'm dropping
this and stuff but um maybe it's still
gonna work somehow
okay let's defend a little bit my center
queenside castle no no I don't want a
queenside castle my Brooke wants to be
here take the knight he's free free
night free nights for everybody come on
just take him he's free he's a free
night let's go let's go let's go let's
roll here okay I insist I'm coming to H
to grab here Forks and everything Oh
grab a rope push a pawn but not now I
want to break this down I could push
here soon I could grab this but this is
crumbling now let's do this now I'm on
the Queenie Queens hit Knight takes pawn
you know that what's the scoop
okay whoa what I might be dropping a
rook okay open up open up open up what's
the time count okay I'm good on time
don't you dare fall for a mate in one
you do know mayhem ones to kill the
night next I was ready to push here okay
no no no no no no no let's just do this
what's the clock situation it's good
okay just anything is anything didn't
have any time right right here no time
cream of no no no no no let's not do
that
just hang on hang on flying why'd I let
them get a queen check 128 125 96 I only
have nine games and they have 12 and 11
games in that's a lot
okay e4e 4 d 4 let's do this um dark
squares dark squares got the Queen
pre-move okay my Knights want to get to
f6 and d6 really soon really soon I'm
gonna be made
ah man okay oh boy making one me in one
threat what's the scoop natan one yes
that was a quick win no it's not it's
not me
it's [ __ ] the bow it's not me I'm
seeing ghosts uh seeing ghosts and what
is okay I have I have this where's the
main I just want it to be made this is
so hard to get oh oh where's there mate
ah there had to be something better
trading Queens
ah man so much for a quick win has come
by chickens way too fast fast chicken
counter oh just grab a rook grab that
rook okay I got that mate okay they
resign back to tournament 145 128 116 11
minutes and change a lot of time left
still what three four more games maybe a
fifth somehow okay what can we have here
okay I'm on the night and okay I'm ready
to give a check that could be a problem
big problem no it might be an
in-betweener in-betweener
okay let's guard this watch out for
those Inbetweeners that right there and
then night a four I think was good I
have the a file for my pieces maybe
Bishop here and it is there and oh I
have the Queen this is me resign resign
resign come on this is time to resign
isn't it resign come on
hmm don't make me earn this one don't
make me earn it
what did I do okay
all right oh the night's gonna hit my
queen
and this ponds falling okay maybe not I
got the bishop covered I have this
Knight also and I'm on the bishop they
could take that let me take this and I
can give check look right here and then
it's me no not quite
um I guess that and this and then that
oh let's try it again this isn't just a
drop the better not be oh that's me
that's me that's me back determine what
we got 136 points heat what's 78 175 136
what are those guys eating oh man they
got a beefy score let's go each pond I
need you to save the day get out of
there night
get out of there night there we go
oh I just dropped that no I didn't okay
go here establish a pond in the center
maybe okay aged six one day from now get
out of there night
stop Knight g4 stuff okay that night
seems like it's close to dead it's on
the edge okay I'm gonna commit commit
okay dark squares whoa whoa whoa whoa
what's going on with these dark squares
here my opponent is um they don't have a
dark square bishop do they and I'm gonna
pin okay let's get out of this pin I'm
on the night Bishop takes Knight as a
threat it's defended
this is scary over here man okay let's
just castle though this side I guess
take that night
what are those Knights up to Oh take a
rook
it's free where is it oh man what's
happening okay is everything okay it
better be okay I think I want to just
take that night okay I'm going to I
think I might have just acted anyhow
check can't get rid of my knight Canyon
let's open this up over here deflection
take the rook and then give me
deflection here I have that square
covered this is me coming up right here
don't be a time ticker
don't you dare their time tick here
these are precious seconds ah these are
precious seconds come on what's going on
here less than 5 au x occur 7 minutes
and change let's go I got 22 18 199 or
yeah 218 195 how do you have 218 what's
happening to get to 18 okay let's open
this up here take that guy first and
okay give me a pun okay I got a pond
looking for a fork next okay we're gonna
have the there's no quick win here no
quick wins in sight right here I guess
development defend that pond and my
bishops probably gonna get hit tonight
to be 5 or that okay I gotta give up
some material I guess alright let's just
push here and then get to this square I
guess I have to be cautious of Forks
okay let's do this instead
get out oh I'm in a fork again
okay can I be sneaky sneaky move the
night ah this is bad news bad nose here
okay that's not how a pawn captures okay
so ah
there's just no quick wins none in sight
I'm on the bishop King position get this
pawn rolling no my night I could rely
upon that Square and that's that's
dropping but I get a check
tricky check and then pawn push and then
right here next this is working somehow
it's working okay got to give that up no
time no time time to resign okay any
move just burn the clock right there
okay back to German 22:38 215 176 I'm
not even close what is happening here
why can't I get a quick win no quick
wins no no quick resigner czar actually
I did have some fairly quick resign errs
they must have had even quicker resign
first let's go clean do something do
something open this up here f7 h7 okay I
got some material where's the main okay
I have an idea
no I don't a knight I fight and then I
was gonna play there okay
rook up and over I should have done
something right here I guess what is
that even doing uh look up and then over
I didn't even realize up that that could
be captured I want to stay on this file
okay the Knights pinned and this pawn is
pinned also I just want to pile up on f6
there's gonna be a capture there okay
now I'm gonna take here this has to be
good
okay this has to be good where is the
mate real soon it's happening don't tell
me you're gonna milk the clock here
don't you dare
yes back to term at 196 can I catch up
to second at least to 58 they have five
more games in second place has three
more games I need to get paired up with
maybe the the second place guy all right
let's roll here oh the wind gambit let's
do this all right and I'm gonna do this
it looks a little weird but I'm gonna
try it and to take here I guess the
queens are coming off huh queens are out
of here and my nights gonna have to run
home or is he know let's try this pawn
push a couple times okay I got some
material I think by force see if I'm
right no I don't know about force I
force no I got to break this knight
takes is on I think I want to just hit
that pond for another time here I should
have just taken that while I had the
chance
okay I'm ready to remove that night okay
I could take this pun what's the clock
count ah
these aren't anything from being fast
wins let's get out of that pin Bishop
check Oh bishop pin that's brutal
that's that's got to be resignation come
on you know it
okay back to tournament 216 oh I'm
within striking distance of second
striking distance of second here two
minutes and change I gotta win two more
games I think in a very little time open
this up here okay oh oh can we have it
I'm setting it up it's ready to be
launched
it's ready to be launched now bishop
here stops everything or does it uh-oh
it's happening here Oh No
they shouldn't just reacted man I have
to call it off I have to call off the
fishing trip here it's not happening and
I guess we have to trade a little bit I
got I have a piece up but not gonna be a
quick win
let's get that Bishop out of there and
okay I'm gonna take that and then this
and then the coast is clear
one minute 53 what's the scoop here pin
the knight kill the knight reposition
get my knight on f5 that is a weak
square get my King involved I could grab
this pond any day right now is a good
one g4 no matter what age 5 to get my
knight to this square forking Forks rook
hear that it's a deadly fork and just
take this and where is the quick mate
where's the quick mate one minute 19
come on go go go go go oh so many mouse
lips right here and then move my knight
next and then pun pun and then pond one
more one more one more okay precious
seconds back to term in 236 oh look at
this this is ridiculous
24 games I need quick resign errs
everywhere it's my only hope
I need 18 quick resign errs to get that
top guy 18 quick resigns in a row yeah
it's gonna happen better chance of the
Mega Millions right there oh man just
Castle it's safe and sound over there
right now no trades queenside castle d5
coming up d5 be prepared 20 there's only
22 seconds I'm not even a get this win
ah it's not happening I don't even know
what that move is doing okay get I
should get on this file soon hit the
Queen she's uh she's oh that's it that's
it that's it I get the third place
confetti man Oh what is happening here
let me close out close out of that good
games look at this
24 games does it sound like I'm
complaining maybe because I am ah man 24
games should I do it I'm ready to see
how that was happening I can't help but
wonder how many quick resigner did I get
24 games there had to have been quick
resign errs I'm diving into it let's see
I'm going fishing what is the scoop here
game history I'm tracking it down I'm
getting to the source of this show the
tournament games what's this a group of
1 to 20 you have to actually go into the
other list ah let's see 1 2 3 4 ok these
weren't quick resign errs ok those are
good what about this one though wait a
second hmm no quick resign errs except
for this guy and this one Wow good
tournament only two that's not bad I
thought there'd be more than that so
like 22 games are actually played that
is fantastic